elisabeth deux franchises une dernière
fois le portail de buckingham au rythme
lourd d'une marche funèbre et de coups
de canon à chaque minute
hier en début de soirée un mur de feu
continu de dévorer la forêt entre somos
et sainte hélène le prélude d'une
nouvelle nuit acharnée contre les
flammes ou peut être étonné de la
longueur
de tout ce processus
vous savez les britanniques se sont
plutôt
lents
ils luttent à armes inégales
avec de simples tuyaux et de pelles ses
habitants de la commune de saumos en
gironde font tout leur possible pour
éteindre les flammes
[Musique]
le vent principal ennemi ces rafales
sont susceptibles de raviver les
lisières toujours fumantes en tout trois
mille six cent vingt hectares ont été
consumés depuis lundi derrière le
cercueil le roi charles iii sa soeur et
ses deux frères william et harry
s'affichent côte à côte pour une lente
procession dans les rues de londres il
ya quelques jours en clin d'oeil alors
que le personnel du prince charles se
démenait après l annonce de la mort de
la reine a reçu tous ont reçu une lettre
leur disant que leur mission prenait fin
et donc une plupart vont être licenciés
ce qui a provoqué pas mal d'émotion si
ce n'est de colère ce qui est rassurant
c'est aussi que notre roi charles iii a
eu le meilleur mentor possible et ce
sera un roi excellent
sané
le président de la république s'apprête
à enflammer le climat social dans notre
pays c'est un président de la république
qui se balade avec un jerrycan dans la
main et avec un briquet dans l'autre
main nous allons ainsi limiter les
hausses de prix à 15 % pour le gaz en
janvier 2023 et à 15 % pour
l'électricité en février les situations
de coupures programmées même dans un
scénario dégradé peu probables sont
évitables si la mobilisation de tous est
forte nous maintiendrons un bouclier qui
protège l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
que nous demanderons un certain nombre
de nos compatriotes
d'absorber une hausse de prix pour qu on
soit pas complètement déconnecté du
marché et que nous continuerons à
protéger les plus fragiles selon les
chiffres du gouvernement la hausse
moyenne des factures sera de 25 euros
par mois pour les ménages qui se
chauffent au gaz et 20 euros pour
l'électricité
je suis là pour dire la vérité aux
français je pourrais dire partout dans
le monde l'électricité augmentent de 40
50 cent pour cent et en france l'état va
tout prendre et vous n'allez pas voir
votre facture augmenter mais enfin ce
que les français ne payerait pas
aujourd'hui sur leur facture ils le
paieraient peut-être demain ou après
demain en impôts et c'est ça qu'on veut
éviter de hausse des coûts des prix
d'électricité et du gaz pour les ménages
va coûter 45 euros par ménage par mois
or ce qu'elle propose c'est un chèque
maximum de 200 euros en une fois c'est
adrien 80 ce qui est visé par une main
courante de son épouse à la suite d'une
dispute autour de leur divorce pourquoi
on en parle parce que le député du nord
et son épouse céline quatre noms sont et
craint un communiqué en appelant au
respect de la vie privée main courante
dans laquelle elle fait état de cette
dispute jeu reprend les termes à qui
l'on utilisé dans leur communiqué commun
donc cette dispute du 29 août mais aussi
où elle évoque d'autres faits notamment
un épisode survenu le 2 septembre est
également des faits antérieurs survenus
avant l'été